there's a lot of battlefield 2042 news
today a new specialist map and mode have
been teased a massive patch just dropped
and big changes are happening at dice in
ea
following 2042's rocky launch ea has
announced a major shake-up at the
company dice general manager oscar
gabrielson is leaving with rebecca kutaz
set to take over as the new gm meanwhile
respawn co-founder vince sempela will
become the overall boss on the
battlefield franchise in addition to his
current role ea also indicated it's
looking to create a connected
battlefield universe and both ripple
effect and halo veteran marcus leto's
new studio will be working on
battlefield experiences which may or may
not be new games unfortunately many of
these future plans remain very vague for
the time being but you can read all
about everything we know on that at
gamespot.com
alongside the launch of today's major
new update for battlefield 2042 ea has
spoken a bit about what's next for the
game that includes the launch of a new
map and specialist which will hit next
year as well as time limited 64 player
modes for pc and new gen consoles
following the third update a new patch
is planned to arrive for battlefield
2042 later in december
but it's next year that we'll bring with
it a slate of new content including a
map called exposure while we didn't get
any specific details about its setting
or what it will involve ea tells
gamespot that it will be something
special by saying it takes map design to
a whole new level just what that means
is anyone's guess at this point 2022
will see the launch of the game's first
live season and will also be getting a
new specialist as well as weapons
gadgets and vehicles over the course of
the year we'll also get multiple seasons
each with its own set of new content
further specifics have not been shared
and we don't yet know the release
schedule for any of this
with the release of the new patch rush
mode can now be played on 2042's new
maps and weekly missions have been
reintroduced later in december ea will
add limited time matchmaking modes
allowing both conquest and breakthrough
to be played with just 64 players on pc
and ps5 xbox series x and s on these
platforms the modes are normally played
with 128 players one of the game's new
features with the launch of the new gen
hardware with the 64 player cap in place
for the last gen consoles ea also
reiterated its intent to continue
improving the core experience in the
wake of complaints about the game's
launch that will continue in the next
patch coming later this month and the
company said it's working to bring back
conspicuously absent fan favorite
systems such as a scoreboard it's also
working on unspecified improvements to
social systems
as far as today's patch goes for
battlefield 2042 well it's massive and
brings with it more than 150 bug fixes
changes and improvements across the game
as detailed by dice some of these
changes include improved level geometry
so that players don't get stuck the
elimination of various visual glitches
fixing the spawning issues and
adjustments to various collision issues
but that's just the tip of the iceberg
major changes are also coming to
battlefield 2042's ui the collection
screen is getting adjusted to make it
easier to use and clearer as to what
players are actually selecting new
indicators will soon show you which
players can revive you when you're
downed as well as indicators for players
that can provide health or ammo if you
are low on either enemy vehicles and
players will now also display health
bars when looked at from certain
distances
big additions are coming to the game's
battlefield portal mode as well
alongside various bug fixes for the mode
new builder options have been added such
as rush game modes for all of 2042's all
out warfare maps a new vehicle team
deathmatch mode and new official
templates for game types like gun master
and infection the update looks to also
fix a hit registration issue that has
been plaguing the game one that causes
bullets to deal no damage to enemy
targets dice says in the patch notes
that further improvements are still
being investigated in regards to this
issue battlefield 2042's launch has been
far from smooth early access players
frequently encountered server issues and
bugs while things have steadily improved
since then such as the thanksgiving day
update the buff weapon accuracy there is
still room for improvement dice is
currently planning at least one more
small patch for early december that will
bring more bug fixes as well as balance
changes you can read the full update
number three patch notes on gamespot.com
and be prepared because it's a lengthy
one
a lot of the time fixing one bug can
cause another according to a post from
the battlefield direct communication
twitter account some players on pc have
been unable to make horizontal mouse
inputs since downloading the patch
simply put it means they can't even look
both ways before crossing the street
naturally being unable to look left or
right in battlefield 2042 as it would in
any game is completely ruining the
experience for some players on pc that
being said there is a fix for the bug
but players will have to be willing to
lose all of their in-game settings to
implement it to re-enable horizontal
inputs on pc players will have to
navigate to my documents battlefield
2042 settings and then in their file
directory delete their prof save files
removing these files will restore the
game to his default settings which also
means losing any custom keybinds players
may have set however according to the
fan run twitter account battlefield
bulletin players only have to delete a
set number of lines in one file along
with that bug battlefield 2042
developers have noted an uptick in the
unable to low persistence data error
that prevents players from connecting to
a match
the error infamously stopped countless
users from getting into games after it
launched in early access this past
november unfortunately for players
there's nothing they can do to fix this
issue it's entirely server side so
they'll just have to wait for the game's
developers to address it
but wait there's even more battlefield
2042 news as the game might be adding
some seasonal themed skins according to
a leak including a santa costume for one
of the game's specialists which just
reminds me that we're somehow in
december already but okay if you've
hopped into battlefield how does the new
update feel any other new bugs popping
up anywhere let me know in the comments
and be sure to leave a like and
subscribe so you don't miss your next
episode of gamespot news
[Music]
you